earlier this year Bobo got advised from
many celebrities like Baron haltandy
Richter Fred Armisen Michael Rappaport
Jeff Probst they all try to help him and
became celebrity coaches to teach Bobo
how to ask questions of me yeah and uh
so of course it got us thinking would
Bobo allow himself to be coached by
clips of Sylvester Stallone that we cut
up from his Instagram account
and uh Bobo Santa's office which he
redecorated with Stallone memorabilia
including a collectible Rocky
heavyweight belt and the and the zoom
session started and fake Stallone could
barely get a word in hello hello yes hey
Sly how you doing I can't tell you just
what an honor and a privilege to be on
the phone talking to you you know with
your success as a brilliant act and
screenwriting incredible Rocky franchise
that spanned for decades it's such an
honor to talk to you you know and uh and
I'm very excited to see Tulsa King your
TV series on Paramount plus which is
going to Premiere Sunday November 13th
oh really yeah I follow you on Instagram
too and you know you have a lot of great
sayings you know follow your heart but
take your brain with you you know and
keep punching and keep punching I love
that because that's how when I have some
tough times I'm going through right now
and uh I tell you I keep hearing your
voice keep punching and that's what I do
get back up you know try something new
be adventurous and you'll just keep
punching that's it that's it so Bobo
first of all where do you call off how
do you where do you come up with calling
them A sly I mean you don't even know
that yeah right off the bat
and why don't why don't you have a
conversation with I mean by the way I
will tell you and this is a fact we
timed it I cut that down the ramp was 15
minutes of Bobo just and
why when you're talking to a guy do you
start like giving him full plugs like um
which premieres on you know you're not
doing a show you're talking to the guy
no I know I'm just so excited I guess to
get that all out so moving into the
conversation to tell you how silly this
all is at Bobo's request fake Sylvester
Stallone gives him advice on how to
become a better caller and it really
didn't matter how random the advice was
bubble found a way to make it all make
sense do you have any words of wisdom
any motivation advice on how to be the
best caller since you are the best and
maybe how my questions could be more
impactful
um old skin must be shed before a new
skin can grow right I don't know if that
makes sense but that's pretty much the
truth yeah well this everything you say
makes sense you know this thing went on
for uh I mean Chris right it was just
going on and on so I ran the drops on
this Howard and when I make a call like
this to an internet show or a Mark we we
take great effort to make the drop sound
natural and real like you're talking to
a real person we made no such effort
with Bobo so we finally got out of it I
mean it went on for a really long time
and then we just set the ball but
semester's got to go ask one final
question and then he did any words of
advice from the great uh Sylvester
Stallone here
so as Rocky would say
it ain't over until it's over keep
punching that's that keep punching thank
you so much sly
[ __ ] you
awesome
thank you keep punching buddy
says to him keep punching he goes okay
buddy keep punching I loved it I love
when you say that